parce que voulez vous mettre avec eux
comme ça vous remplissez chacun je vais
mettre un petit quelque chose dans
l'hôtel insectes pour y compris des
morceaux de tuiles un peu de paille ou
encore du bambou dans cet hôtel à
insectes les élèves de l'école de
lavilledieu à elancourt offre le gîte et
le couvert aux petites bêtes
on a posé des du bois pour les animaux
pour que comme ça y vivent
il vise dans l'hôtel bien impressionnant
parce que on les protège
pour qu'ils vivent dans l'intention de
vevo dit oui dix étudiants en
environnement anime ces ateliers autour
de la biodiversité en ville
ce projet fait partie de leur cursus
mais c'est eux qui ont choisi de se
diriger vers les écoles pour
sensibiliser les plus jeunes à la
protection des personnels abeilles
solitaires et autres coccinelle on
essaye de d'intéresser les enfants la
biodiversité et surtout les enfants
c'est bien de parler théorie mais bon si
rien de concret le message passe pas
forcément donc c'est pourquoi on leur
fait un hôtel à insectes chez dans leur
école on n'espère pas susciter des
vocations au moins faire avoir un impact
sur leur vie de tous les jours une
initiative accueillie avec enthousiasme
par les enseignants car pour les ce1 et
cm1 c'est une façon ludique de parler du
programme
et ça marche je crois que tu as en c1
c'est un sujet qui les touche énormément
quitté jarre voilà c'est dit en fonction
encore très curieux donc parler de la
nature de tout ce qui nous entoure
ça y est tu touches ils sont très très
participatif c'est vraiment intéressant
l'école elle-même s'implique dans ces
questions de préservation du vivant
puisque les élèves ont déjà fabriqué des
lombricomposteurs avec les beaux jours
il devrait se remettre au jardinage dans
leur mini potager